You might think your hair and eye color are
permanent, but in reality, they could change
at ANY TIME.
And it definitely already changed once.
Greetings programs, Trace here for DNews.
Many babies are born with blue eyes, and then
their eyes change color as their genes continue
to develop.
Hair color is the same way, sometimes, babies
are born with very light colored hair which
gradually darkens.
We got a few questions on this, so we did
the digging!
The colored part of the eye is the iris, it
controls how much light is let into the eyeball
and it's color is determined by melanin, just
like skin and hair.
Darker colors absorb more light, and lighter
colors reflect more.
Eye color is determined by a few different
genetic factors, the most important being
OCA2.
OCA2 produced melanocytes, or melanin producing
cells.
Melanin is the protein that creates skin,
eye, and hair color.
More melanin means darker eyes, hair, or skin.
The COLOR of the melanin in the eyes is determined
by three OTHER[a] genes, EYCL1, 2 and 3.
Together, they account for brown/green/blue
but not hazel or grey eyes, science is still
working on how we get those.
All blue-eyed people can trace their ancestry
back to a single human born between 6 and
10,000 years ago.
Due to a genetic mutation, a human was born
with a tiny switch right before the OCA2 gene,
that limits the expression of the melanin,
kind of like diluting the stream of the protein.
Individuals with albinism or Albinos have
the OCA2 gene completely shut off -- so their
skin, eyes, and hair have no melanin at all!
With this in mind, let's apply it to babies.
When we're born, our genetics are decided,
but the body hasn't necessarily acted on all
the genes in your DNA.
When it comes to eye color, the melanin controlled
by the OCA2 gene is diluted and thus we all
have blue eyes.
For those with that blue-eye gene mutation
they eyes stay blue.
But for the vast majority of us, once we're
born the OCA2 gene kicks into gear, creating
melanocytes to make proteins and the eyes
turn a different color, somewhere between
9 months and two years after birth.
A medium amount of the melanin makes eyes
green or hazel, a large amount makes them
brown.
With regard to hair, the melanin builds up
the same as in eyes, creating a dark color.
As babies age, their melanin levels increase
and their hair will darken.
Hair colors can change well into puberty,
as some genes aren't "switched on" until the
hormones flood the body in adolescence.
Eventually, usually in the 30s, human hair
stops producing melanin and begins to turn
grey.
Basically, it stops adding color to the hair.
Gray hair tends to occur earlier in Caucasians
and later in Asians.
It's important to point out, that not ALL
babies are born with blue eyes.
This mainly occurs with Caucasian babies,
maybe because of the lower levels of overall
melanin due to the lighter skin tone.
Babies of Asian, African and Hispanic genetic
heritages will likely be born with dark eyes
that stay dark.
Funnily enough, 10-15 percent of Caucasians
report their eye color continued to change
into adulthood, so it's possible your peepers
are still not settled!
What's your favorite eye color?
What do you wish you had?
Tell us in the comments and make sure you
subscribe to DNews for more science!
We're here twice a day, every day of the year.
Do you have questions?
Let us know on Twitter @DNews or me @TraceDominguez.
Thanks so much for watching!